Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on CaseFiles, Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. To receive these episodes early and ad-free, you can support CaseFile on your preferred platform.
At around 9pm on Wednesday, a September 22, 2010, a pedestrian walking along the south walkway of the George Washington Bridge came across an abandoned wallet and cell phone. The towering double-decked suspension bridge spans the Hudson River, connecting Fort Lee in New Jersey with New York City's Washington Heights. With 14 lanes of traffic across both levels, it is a vital artery in the region's transport network and holds the distinction of being the busiest motor vehicle crossing in the world. Narrow walkways for pedestrians and cyclists flank the upper deck, with a full crossing on foot taking about 20 minutes. In 2010, only the south walkway was open. The north side had remained
closed since the September 11 terrorist attacks nearly a decade earlier. The discovery of the wallet and cell phone near the midpoint of the George Washington Bridge was reported to the authorities. Inside the wallet was a driver's license and a Rutgers University ID card belonging to an 18-year-old named Tyler Clementi. Tyler himself was nowhere to be found. Authorities contacted Tyler's parents, Joe and Jane Clementi. With no clear explanation as to why their son's belongings would be on the George Washington Bridge, the confused couple wondered if it might be a problem. prank. They reached out to Rutgers University seeking answers. Tyler lived at Rutgers
Bush campus in the New Jersey township of Piscataway, about an hour's drive southwest of the George Washington Bridge. Bush campus is extensive, with thousands of students moving between its various buildings, athletic fields, and residential halls. Its large size means it operates much like a small city, complete with its own uniformed police department. Campus police are specially trained to address the unique needs of the university community. As questions rose as to Tyler Clementi's whereabouts, two Bush campus police officers were tasked with performing a well-being check on the team. Such checks were routine jobs performed as often as once per shift. In most cases, the district. The
student in question was found in a communal space or visiting a friend's dorm room, unaware their absence had raised concerns. The goal of the check was straightforward, locate Tyler and confirm he was safe. It didn't carry the urgency of a missing person designation which triggered a more immediate and intensive investigation. The two officers arrived at Davidson Hall, the dormitory where Tyler lived shortly after 9.30 p.m. It was located in the tree-filled northern part of the campus, tucked away from the university's main hubs. The single-story barracks-style complex consisted of four buildings labelled A through D that housed more than 300 students, most of whom were first years. Tyler Clementi lived in Building C, commonly
referred to as Davidson C. The two officers entered the building, passing through the central lounge, a popular common area with a television, vending machines, and both pool and ping pong tables. Tyler was not there. The officers continued down a hallway toward room 30, the two-person dorm where Tyler lived. They knocked and knocked without success. Finally, the door eventually opened to reveal Tyler's roommate, 18-year-old freshman Darun Ravi. He was alone and appeared to have just been roused from a deep sleep.
The room itself was typical. Both sides were furnished with a bed, desk, set of drawers and a freestanding closet for each resident. Nothing stood out as unusual. Daroon explained that he'd last seen Tyler sometime between 4.30 and 5 p.m., roughly four hours before Tyler's belongings were found on the George Washington Bridge. Since Daroon had no classes on Wednesdays, he'd spent most of the day alone in room 30. When Tyler had come in that afternoon, he'd sat briefly at his desk, then rifled through his book bag. Derun was called out of the room by a friend, and by the time he returned, Tyler was gone. He hadn't taken his book bag with him.
Derun assumed he'd gone to get dinner. The officers asked about Tyler's demeanor, if anything seemed unusual, whether he'd mentioned any plans, ever stayed away for long periods, or if there were places he usually hung out. Daroon reported nothing out of the ordinary. However, when asked if Tyler had been with anyone recently, Darun mentioned a male visitor who'd stayed in their room two nights earlier on Sunday, September 19. When Darun woke the next morning, the man was gone. He described the man as slightly overweight with short black hair and a scruffy beard.
He'd looked significant. significantly older than a typical student, so Deroon had assumed he wasn't one. Deroon didn't know the man's name or have any way of contacting him. Aside from that, the next few days had been uneventful, with minimal interaction between Deroon and Tyler as they attended their classes. Since nothing about the situation seemed especially serious, the officers saw no reason to take notes, collect evidence, or conduct a detailed search of the room. Their conversation with Deroon lasted under five minutes.
He was polite, cooperative and forthcoming, giving no cause for concern. Before leaving, the officers asked him to get in touch if he remembered anything else, or if Tyler returned. The officers also spoke with the residence in touch. nearby rooms and others milling about the hall. Tyler had only moved into Davidson C about three weeks earlier, so not many of the roughly 80 residents knew him well. Those who did described the bespectacled fresh-faced and small-statured teen as the smiling hallmate because of his friendly disposition. Still, he didn't draw much attention. As one put it, he was the shyest student in the dorm.
No one had information regarding Tyler's whereabouts or the man who had stayed in his room on Sunday night. Surveillance cameras mounted at the front and rear of the building likely captured footage of Tyler's mystery guest, but the video had yet to be reviewed. In the meantime, the officers left Davidson C., notified a supervisor and filed a brief report. As hours passed with still no sign of Tyler, they returned to the dorm to check if he had come back. By then, no one was answering the door to room 30. Those who'd interacted with Tyler on the day he disappeared recalled nothing unusual.
He had spoken to his mother on the phone that morning and sounded like his typical calm composed and contemplative self. Later that afternoon, he participated in a three-hour rehearsal with the Rutgers Symphony Orchestra, where he played violin. He sat beside the same violinist as usual, and they discussed the challenging passage they were working on. They took notes together and chatted about upcoming events. By all accounts, it had been a positive day for Tyler, capped off by the news that he had been granted free violin lessons. When Tyler failed to reappear over the following days,
speculations spread across Bush campus that the older man who'd visited Tyler on Sunday night was involved in his disappearance. As the search continued, investigators discovered that shortly before he vanished, Tyler had downloaded the Facebook app to his cell phone. He then posted what would be his final status update on his page. It read, jumping off the George Washington Bridge, sorry. Tyler Clementi had been eager to begin his freshman year at Rutgers University. As New Jersey's oldest, largest and top-ranked public institution, Rutgers had a strong reputation in academics, health care and research, making it an ideal launch pad for Tyler's next chapter after high school.
An introvert with a slight build, short reddish hair and glasses, Tyler was something of an old soul. He loved musicals and opera, decorating his computer desktop with playbill covers from Fiddler on the roof and Journey Zand. While his peers gravitated towards more mainstream interests, Tyler preferred gardening, cycling and cooking. He grew up in the New Jersey village of Ridgewood and had two older brothers. Their father Joe oversaw the public works department in a neighbouring town while their mother Jane worked as a nurse. Together, Joe and Jane provided their sons with a humble and modest upbringing defined by love. Yet, navigating adolescence wasn't particularly easy for Tyler. He found it easier to be friends with girls
than boys, though he wasn't especially close to anyone. While he valued solitude, he often worried others mistook this for him wanting to be left alone, as he once confided to an acquaintance online. But that's not true, I need some people in my life, just not as much as most people do. longing for deeper connections, he searched online for tips on starting conversations and studied unspoken social rules. Tyler wanted to have at least three close friends, but his shy and gentle demeanour meant he often went unnoticed. His high school principal described him as someone who wasn't that loud, boisterous personality. He wasn't a student that would be standing out front in a pep rally. He would contribute in a different way in maybe a little more humble and
quieter way. There was one place where Tyler did command the spotlight on stage with his violin. The violin was Tyler's voice, his former music teacher said. When he picked his violin up, you noticed. Whether playing Twinkle Twinkle Little Star as a child or tackling Beethoven in later years, Tyler's performances radiated a confidence and enthusiasm that seemed almost at odds with his otherwise reserved nature. His talent was undeniable. As a teenager, Tyler performed for a season with the state orchestra and spent six more with a youth orchestra, earning the role of co-concert-master. The director called him one of the finest violinists they had in their program over the past 42 years. In high school, he was awarded the Festival of Young Performers Scholarship.
He even taught himself to play the violin while unicycling, prompting one astonished onlooker to remark, Wow, who would have thought that was in Tyler? Yet, Tyler was somewhat ambivalent about these accomplishments. Since age 15, he'd questioned his dedication to music and whether he had the focus to pursue it seriously. Alumni from Juilliard, a prestigious performing art school in New York City, encouraged him to apply, but Tyler wasn't sure that was what he truly wanted. In his final year of high school, he began exploring other paths such as biochemistry, pharmaceuticals, and even accounting. At one point, he considered community college, admitting to an online acquaintance that the appeal
was mostly about escape. I feel very defeated by high school, he confided. I hated the whole thing. After weighing his options, Tyler ultimately chose to attend Rutgers University and major in biology. He didn't give up the violin entirely, auditioning for the university. University's second-tier orchestra. Though clearly socially awkward, Tyler's talent stood out. The university's director of orchestras was so impressed that he offered Tyler a coveted
spot in the symphony orchestra, a group typically reserved for upper-classmen and doctoral music students. Tyler was one of only two first-year students accepted. The director hoped he would eventually embrace his. his musical gift and consider switching to a music major. Before starting his first semester, Tyler applied to live on campus. Through the university's housing application website, he found out he had been assigned to Davidson C with a randomly selected roommate, another 18-year-old freshman named Darun Ravi.
Curious to learn more, Tyler searched for Dharvey. Arun Online. Both lived in New Jersey with their families, but their similarities ended there. Unlike Tyler, who was relatively tech illiterate and rarely used social media, Daroon was a tech-sabby computer whiz with a prominent online presence. By late 2010, he had posted more than 2,000 Times on Twitter alone. Daroon was the oldest of two sons and lived in the affluent township of Plainsborough. His father was a software engineer and his mother was a homemaker with a liberal arts degree. Since immigrating from India in the 1990s, the family had done well financially, so much so that
Deroon drove a BMW in high school. Compared to Tyler, Deroon seemed. to find life easy. Photos shared online showed a confident young man mature beyond his years with a heavy five o'clock shadow, a sunny disposition and an athletic build. His social life revolved around a tight-knit group of friends he saw almost the daily, some of whom he had known since childhood. When he wasn't playing ultimate frisbee or breakdancing, he was gaming, building PCs, listening to You Too, or watching the Big Bang Theory. His life was filled with social experiences, from youth camps and prom to shooting hoops and
recreational cannabis use. Daroon often boasted about his strong academics and high test scores, which earned him admission to Rutgers where he planned to major in math and economics. When he graduated high school, his doting parents. purchased a dedicated tribute in the yearbook that read, Dear Deroon, it has been a pleasure watching you grow into a caring and responsible person. You are a wonderful son and brother. Keep up the good work.
Hold on to your dreams and always strive to achieve your goals. We know that you will succeed. Yet, Deroon's online persona also depicted someone combative, provocative, provocative, provocative, and immature. One girl described meeting and befriending him, but acknowledged that he wasn't kind to everyone. On the question and answer website FormSpring, when asked, do you love anyone besides yourself, Deroon confidently declared, nope. He added,
I'm hot regardless of the fact that I'm an asshole. Tyler Clementi and Daroon Ravi met for the first time on Saturday, August 28, 2010, the day they moved in to Davidson Sea. Tyler and his parents arrived shortly after the official move-in time. With their help, he began settling into Room 30, claiming the left side as his own. After stepping out to get something to wait, they returned to find Darun and his family in the room. Deroon was focused on setting up his desktop computer and had to be nudged by his father to greet the Clementies. The two new roommates were eventually left alone to become acquainted,
but they failed to hit it off. Tyler messaged a high school friend named Hannah, noting that he and Deroon were sitting next to each other, but hardly speaking. At Davidson C, residents could arrange their first. furniture however they liked as long as it met university safety guidelines. Deroon moved his freestanding closet to create a private cubby-like space where he could change clothes out of view. Tyler found the setup awkward. While he had placed his desk at the
foot of his bed, open to the room and facing a window, Deroon positioned his desk against a wall with his back to Tyler. As a result, Deroon. 's computer screen and the webcam mounted on top faced Tyler's side of the room. Feeling uneasy, Tyler messaged his friend Hannah. I feel like he's watching me, watching him. Hannah encouraged Tyler to start a conversation, but he wasn't sure how to pronounce Deroon's name and worried about making things even more uncomfortable. Davidson C. was overseen by several resident advisors, or RAs, fellow student residents employed by Rutgers to serve as peer leaders, mentors and support figures. They organised
icebreaker events like ice cream socials, group meetings and communal dinners to help new residents mingle. Tyler and Deroon attended many of these events, but their experiences differed. Daroon quickly made an impression with his assertive, outgoing personality, while Tyler went largely unnoticed and became known strictly by face. Four party-loving girls eventually took him under their wing, but he found it exhausting keeping up with them. Meanwhile, Tyler and Darun struggled to connect, though Tyler did suspect that beneath his roommate's swagger lay an intelligent and thoughtful person. In messages to others, Tyler expressed admiration for Deroon's tech skills.
Daroon had created a speech recognition program on his computer that he called Jarvis, named after Tony Stark's AI assistant from the Iron Man films. The system tracked his class schedule and announced when university buses were due. Tyler also noticed that Deroon often stayed out late, seemingly to give Tyler privacy. He described this distance as very considerate and perceptive, appreciating the alone time that helped him recover from the social demands of college. Yet, Tyler grew increasingly frustrated by Deroon's messiness,
like when he left a yogurt container out for days. By the third week of living together, the dynamic inside Room 30 seemed firmly cemented. Tyler admitted to an online acquaintance that he didn't think he had actually ever talked to Daroon, adding, We kind of just ignore each other. When they did interact, their conversations were brief and superficial. Tyler had long had suspicions as to why Daroon showed little interest in getting to know him.
When he had searched for Daroon online before move-in day, He'd found his Twitter feed. Days before they met in person, Daroon had tweeted a link to a thread on a forum for gay men, captioned, Found out my roommate is gay. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. When Darun Ravie applied for housing at Rutgers, he chose not to room with any of his high school friends who were also attending the university. He wanted to expand his social circle and meet me. new people. He had high hopes that he and his soon-to-be roommate would hit it off, become best friends and spend lots of time together. Upon logging onto Rutgers housing application website, Darroon discovered his future roommate's name listed simply as Tyler C. The application included Tyler's email address, a standard feature to help roommates break the ice before move in. Daroon sent Tyler an introductory email, but didn't receive an immediate reply.
Later that night, Darun began chatting online with an old high school friend named Jason. Jason was preparing to start postgraduate studies at another university, but he and Darun kept in touch through instant messaging. Curious about his new roommate, Darun enlisted Jason's help in digging up information. By Google searching Tyler's email address, the pair uncovered a series of posts, mostly on forums about violins and fish tanks. Derun quickly realized that he and Tyler had little in common. Tyler's online activity revealed a certain tech unease, with posts asking for advice on antivirus software and expressing skepticism about newer technology. He's poor, Deroon wrote to Jason with a sad face emoticon, adding,
Dude, I hate poor people. They soon found a print-on-demand website account linked to Tyler. Years earlier, he had created a few custom t-shirts with self-deprecating slogans like, if opposites attract, why isn't anyone attracted to me? Deroon's response was conflicted. I feel bad for him. him, he admitted. On a health-related forum, Tyler had posted about a sudden worsening of his asthma symptoms
and detailed his prescription medication. When no one responded, he followed up with... Anyone? Jason was blunt in his assessment of Tyler, calling him a pussy and a derogatory slur for people with intellectual disabilities. Deroon joined in the mockery. Eventually, Deroon stumbled on a discovery that shocked him. In a message to Jason, written in all caps, he typed,
Fuck my life, he's gay. Darun Ravi had uncovered Tyler Clementi's posts on Just Us Boys, a website geared toward gay men. While the site featured pornography, it also hosted discussion forums covering a range of topics. Daroon directed Jason to a forum post dated four years earlier in 2006. In it, Tyler sought help with the computer hard drive issue. The post wasn't sexual, but it appeared alongside homoerotic advertising. Daroon responded sharply. He spammed to Jason with the message, What the fuck, seven times in a row. Afterwood, he publicly tweeted the link to Tyler's Just Us Boys post with the caption.
Found out my roommate is gay. By this point, Daroon not only suspected that Tyler was gay, but he had a clearer understanding of Tyler's personality and interests. Frustrated, he messaged Jason. I'm literally the opposite of that. Fuck. Jason sympathised, replying that if he were in Deroon's shoes, he would just die. As the two continued their online sleuthing, they found a Facebook page for someone named Tyler C. Poconi, a Rutgers-bound student who openly identified as gay.
What Deroon and Jason didn't realize was that Pocone was not Tyler Clementi, who didn't have a Facebook account at the time. Poconi didn't fit the picture of the nervous, asthmatic, violin-playing introvert Deroon had imagined. Poconi was confident, good-looking, and outgoing. They had served as their high school's class president and newspaper editor and posted videos showcasing their singing talent. Deroon and Jason were struck by Pocone's apparent popularity, especially the number of attractive female friends they had. Still, Deroon was dismissive, writing,
Wow, this guy is really fruity. I'm such a thug compared to him. Deroon remained disheartened about his housing situation, so Jason tried to inject a more hopeful tone. He brought up another gay student at Rutgers named Carter, who Deroon had met during orientation and spoke highly of. Jason wrote, If gay people were like Carter, there wouldn't be a problem with gay hatred.
Despite never having met him, Jason remarked that it was gay people like Tyler C. Pekone who, quote, always stir up trouble and called him a homophobic slur. Deroon replied simply, I know. By the next afternoon, Deroon and Jason were once again discussing Tyler Clementi. Deroon claimed he wasn't bothered by his roommate's sexuality, but expressed concern over how his parents might react. My dad is going to throw him out the window, he wrote. Still mistaking Tyler C. Pekone for Tyler Clementi,
der Roon circulated Pekone's photos and videos to other friends, asking for their thoughts. One remarked that Peconi, who wore their long, wavy hair held back by a headband, looked, quote, like a freaking woman. He went on to warn that Tyler might try to perform non-consensual oral sex on Darun while he slept. Daroon, referencing his self-made AI program, replied, I'll have Jarvis warn me if he tries to rape me at night. What if he wants you, Deroon's friend asked. Won't that get awkward? Derun replied confidently.
He probably would. Why would it be awkward? He'd want me. I wouldn't want him. His friend then saw an opportunity for Deroon to exploit the situation, writing, He'll bring back mad hot girls to your room, and then you can be like, Ladies, I'm not gay. Deroon laughed, then echoed a sentiment he'd shared in his previous conversations with the Jason.
I'm not really angry or sad. I don't care. But he cared enough to message Tyler C. Bacconi online, only to quickly learn that they weren't the Tyler C destined to be his college roommate. Later that same day, Deroon finally received an email reply from the real Tyler Clementi. He messaged a friend about it, referring to Tyler as, quote, gay, but regular gay. Deroon wasn't wrong in assuming Tyler was gay, but the reality was more nuanced. Tyler had been active on the Just Us Boys Forum since he was 14,
though his early interactions were rarely sexual. He knew he was gay even then, but described himself at the time as practically asexual, with little interest in intimacy. He mostly used the forum to chat about innocuous topics like television shows and cars. It wasn't until years later, as college approached, that he began to explore his sexuality more openly.
The summer after graduating high school, Tyler came out to his family. It was a nerve-wracking experience shaped partly by his family's involvement in an evangelical church where homosexuality was viewed as sinful. He started with his brother, James. Six years older, James had always been protective of Tyler growing up. As Tyler opened up about his sexuality, James saw relief and genuine happiness on his brother's face. It felt like a turning point.
They spent hours talking about relationships, sex, homophobia and other subjects that at once felt off limits. James was proud of Tyler's courage to reveal his authentic self. I was really taken aback by how assured and poised Tyler was, he later said. How much better he understood himself. and his desires than I did at 18. Three days before moving to Rutgers, Tyler came out to his parents. While his father Joe was accepting, his mother Jane struggled to understand.
She and Tyler had always been close, and because she had never suspected he was gay, the revelation caught her off guard. She also wrestled with reconciling the news with her religious beliefs. At first, she dismissed what Tyler was telling her. As their conversation deepened, touching on his uncertainty about his faith and his lack of close friendships, emotions ran high. Both were brought to tears. They hugged and exchanged words of love, but Jane remained quiet and somber afterwards as she processed the news. In her words, she grieved the future she had imagined.
for her son, one that included a wife and children. She admitted she wasn't ready to accept the reality of having a gay son and was worried for him. To Tyler, her muted response felt like rejection. Still, Jane made the most of their time together before he left for Rutgers and kept in close contact by phone. Coming out was a conflicting experience for Tyler. While it offered a sense of freedom, it also intensified his feelings of isolation and despair. As his family noted, Tyler was brave and honest about who he was, but this was still a difficult, vulnerable time for him. Wary of how others might treat him, he didn't flaunt his sexuality or disclose it to just anyone. But the fresh start of college also gave Tyler a boldness,
he hadn't felt before. Shortly after arriving, he attended a meeting of the university's bisexual, gay and lesbian alliance and joined websites for meeting other gay men. Tyler soon connected online with a 30-year-old man case file will refer to as Mitchell Bell. After weeks of exchanging online and text messages, Tyler wanted to meet in person. But Mitchell was a closeted gay man and was reluctant to visit Davidson Sea, fearing it might expose his sexuality. Eventually, on Thursday, September 16, 2010, he agreed to meet Tyler on campus. By then, Tyler had been sharing Room 30 with Darun Ravi for a month,
and the two had still barely spoken. But Tyler had grown more confident and assertive since they first started. met. That evening, he texted Deroon to request private use of their shared room, and Deroon agreed. Tyler arranged to see Mitchell again three days later on Sunday, September 19. Beforehand, he again sent Deroon a text requesting use of their room until midnight. Deroon, who was out playing Ultimate Frisbee, agreed once more. He returned to Davidson's see at around 9 p.m. just as Tyler was preparing for Mitchell's arrival. Daroon entered room 30 to grab a few things before heading to the communal showers.
As he gathered his belongings, Tyler asked him, do you need anything else, as a polite way of letting Daroon know not to interrupt his time with Mitchell. But when Tyler collected Mitchell and brought him to room 30, Darun was back to. inside. He barely acknowledged Mitchell, who sat quietly on Tyler's bed, before quickly leaving again. With Deroon gone, Tyler and Mitchell began kissing. As the evening progressed, they both noticed something strange. The light on the webcam on top of Deroon's computer suddenly glowed green, indicating it had switched on. Neither Tyler nor Mitchell had touched the device, and the computer monitor itself appeared off.
There was no practical way for the webcam to activate without someone manually controlling it. Alarmed, Tyler moved toward Deroon's computer with the intent of facing the camera away. But just as suddenly as it switched on, the green light turned off. Mitchell found it difficult to ignore the camera's presence. He thought it was odd that the webcam was aimed at Tyler's side of the room rather than where someone would typically sit at the desk. At around 10pm, Mitchell decided to leave. As he exited Davidson C, he noticed a group of five student residents standing in a corner
staring at him in an unsettling manner. Had they been in the street or somewhere other than this building, I would have asked them why they were looking at me. he later said. Because I was a guest in the building, I wasn't going to ask. Daroon didn't return to room 30 until 2 a.m., at which point he went straight to bed. The following day, Tyler checked Darun's Twitter,
something he'd privately done before but never mentioned. What he found rattled him. At 9-17 the previous night, Derun had posted. Roommate asked for the room till midnight. I went into Molly's room and turned on my webcam. I saw him making out with a dude. Yay. When Tyler had asked for private use of room 30 for the second time in a week, Derun was caught off guard. This time, Tyler made it clear that Deroon shouldn't return early. Oh, you want me to leave, Deroon asked,
realizing he was being effectively shut out until Tyler's guest left. The first time, he'd assumed Tyler was simply having a casual visit from a friend. But now, the insistence on privacy suggested something more. Deroon headed across the hall to Room 29, where an old high school friend of his named Molly Way was staying.
Molly and Daroon moved in the same social circles and had once been really close, though never a couple. At first, Molly trusted him, but that trust gradually gave way to doubt. Daroon often bragged about his supposed fame, claiming he'd appeared on billboards across India and was well known in Canada for snowboarding. He also said he'd captained an all-black basketball team. that won a state championship. Molly suspected these extravagant claims were lies designed to impress her.
When she gently told Darun that he didn't need to exaggerate, he brushed off her scepticism and insisted he was telling the truth. Unconvinced, Molly stopped speaking to him altogether. Later, she learned that Darun had responded to her avoidance by calling her a lying bitch and a whore. When Molly began her pharmaceutical science degree at Rutgers, she prayed to God she wouldn't run into Deroon, having vague knowledge he had enrolled there. Her heart sank on moving day at Davidson Sea when she saw his name taped to the door
directly across the hall. Despite her initial dread, the two gradually re-established a friendly rapport and began hanging out again, mostly on weekends and often in each other's rooms. It was during these visits that Molly met Tyler Clemente. Derun introduced them, but aside from the occasional greeting in the hallway, their interactions were minimal. Derun rarely mentioned Tyler to Molly, except for an offhand comment that he suspected his roommate was gay. On the evening of Sunday September 19, Molly invited Deroon to her room to share snacks. He seemed agitated when he arrived because Tyler had asked to use their room for the night
and was unusually insistent about having uninterrupted privacy. Daroon briefly returned to room 30 just as Tyler was collecting his guest from the building entrance. When the man entered, Deroon said little and quickly left, heading back to Molly's room. Now visibly unsettled, he vented that Tyler had brought back a really old-looking guy and said the whole thing felt off. What the heck, what's going on? he asked nervously. Daroon described Tyler's guest as really shady because of his scruffy appearance
and said he was worried the man might steal his valuables, adding that if anything went missing, Tyler would have to pay for it. He then remarked, Oh, and my roommate's gay. Like, what if something else is going on? Unbeknownst to Tyler, Deroon had long experimented with manipulating webcams beyond their intended use.
His interest dated back to high school where he first explored unconventional setups for a physics project. But it was in the summer before college that his tinkering became more deliberate. He created a custom program capable of remotely activating webcamps, taking photos at set intervals and uploading the images to a website. To mask the software's true purpose, Deroon disguised it and tried convincing friends to install it on their computers. A few did, until they noticed their webcam line.
lights turning on without explanation, and the Ruse unraveled. Undeterred, Deroon sought a workaround and eventually discovered a method to bypass the giveaway light. He also learnt that by adjusting settings in the video chat application iChat, he could configure his computer to automatically accept incoming calls, allowing his webcam to be activated remotely. A little after 9pm in Molly Way's dorm room, Daroon announced that he wanted to demonstrate his webcam setup. He also mentioned that he suspected Tyler might be gay
but wasn't sure about it and wanted to find out for sure. Opening iChat on Molly's laptop, he clicked his own username from her contact list. Just a few feet away in room 30, Deroon's computer received the incoming call. As programmed, the system automatically accepted the connection. There were no sounds, alerts or notifications to indicate that the webcam was activated. The monitor remained dim, giving the impression the computer was off, idle or in sleep mode. But the moment the connection was established, a video feed appeared on Molly's screen showing
a live stream from Room 30. Due to the placement of Deroon's desk, the webcam offered a wide view of Tyler's side of the room. It captured Tyler and his male guest standing near the door, kissing. As soon as it became clear that Tyler was engaged in sexual activity, Deroon quickly terminated the video feed. He and Molly sat in stunt silence. Oh, he is gay, Daroon muttered. Though Durun had long suspected Tyler's sexuality, he hadn't expected to see him act on it. He had assumed that Tyler's shy reserved nature might prevent him from pursuing sexual encounters at all.
Later claiming they were both deeply uncomfortable with what they'd seen and acknowledging that it was an invasion of privacy, Deroon and Molly agreed to keep the incident between themselves and act as though it had never happened. But that pact was quickly broken. Less than five minutes later, using Molly's laptop, Deroon took to Twitter and posted a message to his 150 or so followers, many of them high school friends now attending Rutgers. Roommate asked for the room till midnight, he was. wrote. I went into Molly's room and turned on my webcam. I saw him making out with a dude. Yay. Because his profile wasn't set to private, the tweet was visible to anyone who viewed his feed.
Molly too struggled to keep the incident to herself. She messaged her boyfriend, Austin, who was attending another university. Oh my God, Austin, she typed. Deroon's in my room. We've got to tell you the craziest thing that just happened. Oh my fucking God. She and Deroon passed the keyboard between them, describing in detail what they had seen. When Austin asked whether they had taken a photo,
Molly replied, no. We should have, she said, before deciding, nah, it would be terrible. Austin, who had previously heard Tyler was a good person, nevertheless responded with revulsion, saying the story made him want to throw up. Molly replied, he's nice, but he's kissing a guy right now, like they were groping each other. Ew. Meanwhile, Deroon's tweet started drawing attention on and off campus. Not long after 10pm, a friend from back home replied to it teasingly, calling
Deroon a purve. Word of the incident spread quickly through Davidson Sea, helped along by a Deroon himself. He approached friends with a distraught expression, announcing he had a secret, before divulging what Tyler was up to in Room 30. Molly Way's dorm room became a gathering point for curious residents. Seven students squeezed in as Molly and Deroon filled them in on the details. Eventually, Deroon stepped out with one of them, saying they were going outside to smoke. With Deroon gone, the remaining group, Molly, her roommate and three friends, debated whether to take another look into room 30 via her laptop.
Most felt it was a bad idea, but one friend pushed hard. Molly eventually gave in and clicked on Deroon's I-chat username. The webcam feed appeared. On screen, Tyler and his guest were now shirtless and kissing. Molli quickly shut the stream down, but this time she had mishandled the process. When she remotely activated the webcam, the green light turned on. By the time Tyler moved to investigate, the stream had already been terminated and the light was off. Deroon returned to Molly's room around midnight.
By then, Mitchell Bell had left room 30. Deroon stayed a while, eventually dozing off in a chair. Around 2 a.m., Molly woke him and encouraged him to return to his room. The following day, Tyler saw Deroon's tweet, and it didn't take long for him to piece together what had happened. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. That night, Tyler reached out to his high school friend Hannah. The two began a lengthy online chat about the incident. Hannah was disturbed by what Deroon had done, though she tried to keep her tone calm, not wanting to upset Tyler further. She gently suggested he confront his roommate, but Tyler hesitated. It's not like he left the camera on or recalled. recorded or anything, he wrote. He just like took a five-second peep.
Tyler seemed eager to downplay the violation, attributing Deroon's actions to curiosity rather than cruelty. He also didn't want Deroon to know he'd been monitoring his Twitter feed. Unwilling to brush it aside, Hannah replied, I would feel seriously violated. Tyler acknowledged the feeling. When I first read the tweet, I definitely felt violated, he said. But then, when I remembered what actually happened, I don't know. It doesn't seem so bad. Hannah pushed back. Dude, not only did he peep, he told the entire world about it.
You okay with that? Tyler's real feeling slipped through, if only for a moment. Yeah, he admitted. He's a jerk. His messages were peppered with LOLs and ha-hars, as if trying to convince Hannah or himself, that it wasn't a big deal. But it clearly lingered on his mind. As their conversation continued, Tyler returned to view Deroon's Twitter 38 times. Then, at around 1 a.m., he looked up Rutgers University Student Conduct Code. He found a clause prohibiting the secret recording of audio or video
in situations where nudity or sexual activity might reasonably be expected. Still chatting with Hannah, he considered his options. What if he reported Deroon? Could it get him expelled? It could be interpreted as a hate crime or the development of one, Hannah warned. Tyler wasn't ready to take it that far. After ending his conversation with Hannah at around 1.30, he turned to the Just Us Boys Forum for anonymous advice. He outlined the situation and floated possible ways to prevent it from happening again. I could just be more careful next time, he wrote. Make sure to turn the camera away.
Still, he expressed a desire for Daroon to face some kind of accountability, though he doubted anything significant would come of it. I feel like the only thing the school might do is find me another roommate, probably with me moving out, he speculated. And I'd probably just end up with somebody worse than him. I mean, aside from being an asshole from time to time, he's a pretty decent roommate. Commenters advised Tyler not to escalate the situation, warning that doing so would only stir up more drama.
But after a seemingly restless night, at around 4 a.m., Tyler ignored all prior advice. He logged in to the Rutgers Housing Portal and submitted a request for a single room, citing the reason roommate used webcam to spy on me. Afterwards, Tyler revisited Deroon's Twitter to see how others had reacted to the invasive post. What he found left him disheartened. None of the replies condemned Deroon's actions or acknowledged the seriousness of the violation. Frustrated, Tyler vented on the Just Us Boys Forum.
Other people have commented on his profile. with things like, how did you manage to go back in there? And, are you okay? The friends were treating my making out with a guy as the scandal, whereas, I mean, come on, he was spying on me. Do they see nothing wrong with this? At 4.45 a.m., still unsure what to do next, Tyler turned to the community-driven website Yahoo! Answers. One user urged him to report Derun. calling his behaviour completely inappropriate. They added bluntly, I'm not trying to be mean,
but if you don't have the guts to take control of the situation, it's not going to get better. Tyler reiterated the reasons behind his hesitation, before admitting, I'm just not a great self-advocate. Tyler invited Mitchell Bell to visit him again on the evening of Tuesday, September 21, two days after the incident.
He texted Deroon asking, Could I have the room again at like 9.30 till midnight? Derun replied agreeably, no problem. But moments later, he messaged Molly Way with an update that hinted at his irritation. He wants the room again. Molly responded in disbelief. What the fuck? It's going down tonight also, D'Rourne.
Arunne added, assuming Tyler and his guest would be intimate again. Molly replied, What the fuck? I'm worried for you, LOLO-L. Deroon seemed unfazed, replying casually, I'm going to be at practice anyway, referring to his ultimate frisbee training. Despite sounding indifferent to Tyler's plans, Derun started scheming.
As he walked across campus with friends after dinner that evening, he openly bragged about a plan he'd devised. He intended to live stream Tyler's date in Room 30 to anyone interested in watching. Daroon gave instructions on how to access the stream remotely and announced he was hosting a viewing party in another room, complete with a bottle of rum and beer. He even texted Franz off campus, urging them to tune in. Then, at 6.39 p.m., he tweeted,
Anyone with iChat, I dare you to video chat me between the hours of 9.30 and 12. Yes, it's happening again. Back at Davidson C, Daroon visited the rooms of two other students to test his webcam setup using their computers. One of the students watched the live feed as Darun entered the now empty room. and repositioned his computer so that his webcam directly faced Tyler's bed. As he did so, the student watching remotely gave a thumbs up. Deroon then instructed this student to text others and tell them to check his Twitter. Satisfied that everything was working, Deroon messaged a friend at another university.
I have it pointed at his bed and the monitor is off, so he's. can't see you. It's set to automatically accept. I just tested it and it works. He added half joking. Be careful. It could get nasty. Discussing the plan with another interested viewer, Derun admitted he'd been creeped out since Sunday and said he intended to, quote, keep the gaze away. Around 8.30 p.m., Daroon left Davidson. for Ultimate Frisbee practice, still hyping his planned viewing party. But later that night, when others tried to connect to his webcam, the setup failed repeatedly with an error message. One viewer found Deroon in the central lounge and told him the video
wasn't working. He replied, Yeah, I've been getting that from a lot of people. The following day, Deroon told a friend the stream got messed up. up and didn't work. Truth was, Tyler was still quietly monitoring Darroon's Twitter activity and quickly caught wind of the plan to secretly live stream his date with Mitchell Bell. Alarmed, Tyler decided to act. Before Mitchell arrived, he went to the dorm room of resident advisor Rahi Grover. Behind closed doors, a visibly.
shaken, quiet and uneasy Tyler confided in Rahi about Deroon's behaviour. Recognising the gravity of the situation, Rahi advised Tyler to document everything in an email to file an official incident report. He also offered Tyler the use of the spare bed in his room for the night, but Tyler declined. Returning to room 30, Tyler's first instinct was to unplugged Deroon's computer, eliminating any chance the live stream could proceed. He then messaged his friend Hannah, admitting he felt afraid Deroon might have hidden other webcams. To be safe, Tyler powered down the entire strip controlling Deroon's electronics. Tyler chose not to inform Mitchell Bell about Deroon's actions. Yet, while they were intimate,
the two men overheard laughter and joking voices outside the window above Tyler's bed. Mitchell noticed the blind was slightly ajar and that Tyler was visibly uneasy. Although he hoped to see Tyler again, Mitchell no longer felt comfortable visiting Davidson C. He opted not to stay overnight, wary of creating tension with Deroon, whom he sensed would be uncomfortable sleeping in a room with two gay men. When Mitchell left, Tyler texted Deroon that he could return to room 30. About 15 minutes later, just after midnight on Wednesday, September 22, Tyler composed a formal email to resident advisor Rahi Grover. He outlined the initial incident of Deroon's spying on him via the webcam,
as well as the attempted live stream, including screenshots of Deroon's Twitter posts, Tyler wrote, I feel that my privacy has been violated and I am extremely uncomfortable sharing a room with someone who would act in this wildly inappropriate manner. Rahi immediately filed an incident report with senior management declaring that Daroon had violated Tyler's privacy.
He recommended an immediate roommate reassignment and disciplinary action against Daroon. Later that, night, Tyler returned to the Just Us Boys Forum to explain why he'd finally take an action. Deroon's second attempt at spying, now with an audience, made it clear the first incident was not a mistake. Tyler admitted this escalation set him off and that confronting Deroon directly no longer felt like a viable option. Despite the seriousness of the situation, Tyler's tone remained somewhat lighthearted, still hesitant to take a firm stand, but the invasion of privacy had deeply shaken him.
He confessed that left him feeling paranoid, so much so that he had gone crazy searching Room 30 for other hidden webcams. That afternoon, Resident Advisor Rahi Grover visited Room 30 in accordance with Rutgers' protocol to follow up with those involved in the incident report. Tyler wasn't there, but Darun Ravi was. Without disclosing that Tyler had filed the complaint, Rahi informed Darun that a report had been lodged involving a potential privacy violation
and that he would be contacted by university officials. Darun appeared confused and quite upset by the allegation. When he began to explain his, himself, Rahi quickly stopped him, stating that any response would need to be made to senior staff. After learning he was under investigation, Darun moved quickly to protect himself. He deleted the incriminating tweets he had posted on September 19 and 21, in which he openly described spying on Tyler, outing him as gay, and encouraging others to watch his webcam's live stream. To further obscure his actions, he replaced the September 21 tweet with a misleading message advising
his followers not to video chat with him that night. He claimed the original post encouraging video chats was a draft he'd accidentally tweeted by mistake. Later that afternoon at around five, Tyler returned to Room 30 following orchestra rehearsal. What was said, if anything, between the two roommates remains unknown. But within the hour, Tyler left again. He grabbed a burger at the campus dining hall before making his way to the George Washington Bridge. If Daroon was truly troubled by the growing tension between them, it wasn't apparent in the messages he sent that evening to his high school friend Jason. Derun invited Jason, who was in New York, to visit Rutgers. He jokingly called him a homophobic slur to which Jason replied,
You is gay. Shortly after 8.30 p.m., Tyler walked alone across the South pedestrian walkway of the George Washington Bridge. He went largely unnoticed, though a few passes by later recalled glimpsing him near the midpoint. Tyler downloaded Facebook onto his cell phone, then posted a short. farewell. At the same time, Daroon sent Tyler a message. He wrote, I want to explain what happened. Sunday night when you requested to have someone over, I didn't realize you wanted the room in private. I went to Molly's room and I was showing her how I set up my computer so I can access it from anywhere. I turned on my camera and saw you in
the corner of the screen and I immediately closed it. I felt uncomfortable and guilty of what happened. Obviously, I told people what occurred so they could give me advice. Then, Tuesday, when you requested the room again, I wanted to make sure what happened Sunday wouldn't happen again and not to video chat me from 9.30 to 12. Just in case, I turned my camera away and put my computer to sleep, so even if anyone tried, it wouldn't work.
I wanted to make amends for Sunday night. I'm sorry if you heard something distorted and disturbing, but I assure you all my actions were good-natured. Tyler didn't respond. Ten minutes later, Daroon sent a follow-up message. I've known you were gay and I have no problem with it. In fact, one of my closest friends is gay and he and I have a very open relationship. I just suspected you were shy about it, which is why I never broached the topic.
I don't want your freshman year to be ruined because of a petty misunderstanding. It's adding to my guilt. You have a right to move if you wish, but I don't want you to feel pressured to without fully understanding the situation. It's unclear whether Tyler read either of Deroon's hastily sent explanations before he jumped, into the frigid, dark waters of the Hudson River. Later that night, two Bush Campus police officers arrived at Davidson Sea to conduct a well-being check after Tyler Clementi's abandoned belongings were discovered
on the George Washington Bridge. They knocked on the door of Room 30, but received no response. Across the hall, Molly Way noticed the commotion. Concerned, she called Darun Ravi almost ten times before he finally picked up. Derun, groggy and disoriented, revealed he was actually inside the room. I'm really tired, I want to go back to sleep, he said. When Molly told him that the police were at his door, he got up to speak with them. Despite knowing he'd recently been reported by Tyler, De Roon said nothing about the complaint.
Instead, he deflected suspicion onto Tyler's guest, Mitchell Bell, telling the officers that he was worried he might be involved in something. Early the next morning of Thursday, September 24, word began circulating amongst Rutgers' staff that Tyler Clementi was presumed dead, having likely taken his own life. A group of university staff, including the assistant director of Bush Campus, a representative from the psychology department and resident advisor Rahi Grover, arrived at room 30 to speak with Darun. They informed him of the
situation and encouraged him to return home to Plainsborough pending an investigation. Derun initially resisted, saying, I want to defend my honour. Ultimately though, he agreed to leave campus. Later that afternoon, Darun texted a friend. My roommate committed suicide and stated that he would be staying home until it blows over. When the friend asked if he knew what had caused Tyler to take his own life, Darun responded dismissively. No idea. He was quiet all the time and had no friends, so I guess it makes sense. Deroon's friend seemed surprised. I thought he had friends, he replied, then followed up with a pointed question.
Didn't you say there was like a viewing party once and didn't he have another guy or something? Deroon attempted to distance himself from his previous actions. No, he quickly replied. That was a joke. A week later, Tyler's body was discovered floating in a waterway off the Hudson River about a mile and a half north of the George Washington Bridge. The fall had caused a blunt force trauma, but the official cause of death was drowning. Investigators confirmed the suicide through a combination of digital records and a handwritten note found in Tyler's book bag.
By then, the truth about Tyler's final days at Davidson C. had begun to surface. The focus of the investigation turned to Darun Ravi and to the friend across the hall who had witnessed it unfold, Molly Way. On Thursday, September 23, 2010, the day after Tyler Clementi took his life, Molly Way finished class to find she had a missed call from the Rutgers police. While the message didn't specify a reason, Molly suspected it had something to do with Deroon and Tyler, especially after seeing police outside their room the night before.
Molly was picked up and taken to Rutgers' police headquarters for questioning. As officers asked about the webcam incidents, Molly's phone rang. It was Deroon. When she answered and told him she was at the police station and couldn't talk, he hung up and immediately texted. Did you tell them we did it on purpose? Molly replied. Yeah, well, that we didn't know what we were going to see.
Daroon had already crafted a version of events in which he and Molly were simply fooling around with his webcam and hadn't realized Tyler wanted privacy with his guest. But Molly had been more forthcoming with the police. Oh my God, Daroon, she texted. Why didn't you talk to me first? I told them everything. Like what? he asked. Like literally everything, because they asked me to tell them exactly what happened.
Daroon pressed for more details. What did you say when they asked why we turned the webcam on? I said we just wanted to see what was going on, Molly answered. And you said we closed it immediately? Yes, she assured him. Mully admitted she was scared and just wanted to know what was happening. Nothing, Deroon insisted. He continued to probe her about the interview.
Did you say anything about Tuesday? Because I turned off my computer that day. That remark confused Molly. She hadn't been involved in the second incident on Tuesday and didn't know what had taken place. I don't know what happened that day, she replied. Nothing happened, Darun assured her. But rumours got started. He thought people were watching him Tuesday. To Molly, it was obvious Deroon was trying to recast the events as misunderstandings to avoid responsibility. Later that day, investigators arrived in Plainsborough to interview Darun Ravi.
They quickly noticed how he downplayed the spying incidents, framing his actions as concern for his personal belongings rather than an act of voyeurism. He claimed that Mitchell Bell appeared shady and said he had only activated the webcam to make sure no one was rifling through his things. Deroon also insisted he had no issue with Tyler's sexuality and that the live stream never took place because he had second thoughts. and shut down his computer beforehand. He even repositioned the webcam to face his own bed so that if anyone did manage to access it, they wouldn't see anything compromising. He called his actions immature and insensitive,
but denied any hateful intent. But the evidence painted a picture of a frightened young man scrambling to cover his tracks. Investigators determined it was Tyler, not Deroon, who had shut down the computer before the attempted live stream. When police examined Room 30 after Tyler's death, the webcam was still pointed directly at Tyler's bed, clearly contradicting Deroon's account.
Deroon had also tampered with evidence by deleting the incriminating tweets. His remorseful messages to Tyler sent within minutes of his final farewell on Facebook suggested another last-ditch attempt to distance himself from what was about to unfold. As Tyler's tragic story spread, it sparked a global outpouring of grief and outrage. At Rutgers, vigils were held, flowers were placed at a makeshift memorial, and students wore black in mourning. An empty seat was reserved for Tyler at what would have been his debut performance, with the Rutgers Symphony Orchestra. The college football team observed a moment of silence
as more than 100 people attended a campus rally chanting, If my dorms not safe, Rutgers isn't safe. The incident laid bare the vulnerabilities LGBTQ plus youth often face, particularly concerning privacy, bullying and mental health. As one Rutgers student put it,
Had Tyler been in bed with a woman, this would not have happened. He wouldn't have been outed via an online broadcast, and his privacy would have been respected, and he might still have his life. Many felt Deroon's tweet, I saw him making out with a dude, yay, wouldn't have garnered any attention had dude been replaced with chick. The story quickly took on a life of its own, with widespread but inaccurate, claims that Daroon and Molly had recorded Tyler having sex and posted it online. Though factually untrue, this narrative fueled intense online vitriol and calls for the pair to be
charged with murder and sentenced to life in prison. Others condemned what they saw as a mob mentality, arguing that Darun and Molly were just a couple of stupid teenagers who should have known better but didn't. To them, Daroon was just a scapegoat, while the real focus should have been on the adults and institutions that perpetuate anti-gay prejudice. Derun had no shortage of defenders amongst his family and friends, including Rutgers' students who were partly involved in the events. They insisted he harbored no hostility towards gay people, noting he had a close gay friend with whom he'd never had issues. According to them,
Deroon didn't have a problem with Tyler being gay and reacted to it with indifference. They said he rarely spoke about Tyler, and when he did, he referred to him as a nice guy. To them, Deroon was crazy and goofy, immature to the point of absurdity at times, but not intentionally malicious. Others viewed Deroon differently.
The captain of the Rutgers' ultimate frisbee club had spoken with him several times about Tyler. He recalled that while Darun never made overtly cruel remarks, he appeared visibly uncomfortable with Tyler's sexuality. In a message exchange with a friend, Daroon responded to a story about a lesbian couple with ooh and described seeing two men kissing on a stoop in New York with similar distaste. Determining how to proceed was a complex challenge for prosecutors. Under US law, a criminal conviction requires proof that a defendant's actions directly caused a victim's death.
In Tyler's case, this was complicated by evidence showing he had struggled with depression and suicidal thoughts before he ever met Deroon. In writings both online and offline, Tyler had expressed inner turmoil and a sense of hopelessness about his loneliness, sexuality and faith. His computer contained documents titled Sorry and Why Is Everything So Painful? In other personal musings, he confessed, There is nothing in this world that I love. I just want to be deleted.
Other notes echoed similar. despair. Every breath hurts. I wish my breath would stop. God meet me halfway and take me to you. Investigators also discovered that Tyler had previously visited bridges throughout New York and saved photos of the George Washington Bridge on his cell phone, suggesting suicide was something he had been considering for some time. While Deroon's actions were widely condemned, condemned as invasive and cruel, and many believed they led to Tyler's suicide. The prosecution was unable to establish a direct legal link between his conduct and Tyler's decision to take his own life. To Deroon's defenders, even if Deroon's actions were rooted in bigotry,
they did not reflect an intent to cause Tyler's death. As a result of these complexities, charges like homicide or manslaughter were ruled out. Instead, Daroon faced 15 counts relating to invasion of privacy, witness tampering, criminal trespass, and bias intimidation for targeting Tyler based on his sexual orientation, which was classified as a hate crime. Darun Ravi rejected a plea deal that would have spared him jail time in exchange for admitting to the bias intimidation charge, insisting he never hated Tyler and was not homophobic. In contrast, Mully Way accepted a plea deal, entering a pre-trial intervention program to avoid jail and a criminal record. Her agreement required 300 hours of community service, counselling, sensitivity training, maintaining employment for three years, and testifying against Darun at his trial. Darun Ravi's criminal trial began in February 2012, two years after Tyler Clemente's death.
The defence argued that Darun's actions were the result of poor judgment by an immature college freshman, not criminal intent. They maintained he was not driven by hate or bias, highlighting that he had never harassed or spoken negatively about Tyler. The incident they claimed, was a prank that went too far, not a hate crime. The prosecution rejected the defense's portrayal of Deroon's actions as a prank, mistake, or accident. They argued he deliberately set out to brand Tyler as different from everybody else, specifically as gay, to subject him to contempt, ridicule and intimidation. His actions, they said, were intentional, calculated and malicious, not good-natured, as he had implied in his final messages
to Tyler. As the prosecution put it, those acts were meant to cross one of the most sacred boundaries of human privacy, engaging in private, consensual sexual activity with another human being. Daroon sat impassively through much of the trial, often resting his chin on his fist, yawning, and at times appearing to doze off. He was also seen laughing with his defence team. Behind him sat his parents and other supporters, while Tyler's family and friends filled the opposite side of the courtroom. The jury heard testimony from key figures,
including Molly Way, Mitchell Bell, Rahy Grover, and several Rutgers' students who had witnessed Deroon's actions. In his defence, seven character witnesses testified that they had never heard him make derogatory remarks about gay people. The trial lasted 13 days, culminating in the jury finding Darun Ravi guilty on all 15 counts. The judge dismissed Darun's account as a poorly executed attempt to sanitise his motives for using his knowledge of computers to surreptitiously observe. Tyler Clementi and Mitchell Bell in sexual relations. Daroon was sentenced to 30 days in jail, three years probation, 300 hours of community service, a $10,000 fine,
and counselling on cyberbullying and alternate lifestyles. It was an outcome that even some of Darun's supporters labeled a slap on the wrist. Following his sentencing, Darun Ravi gave an exclusive interview to ABC's 2020, expressing regret for his actions while maintaining they were not motivated by homophobia. He explained that his tweets were never meant to hurt or shame Tyler, but were simply life updates for his friends. Looking back, I was very self-absorbed with the whole thing, he said. It was never, what if Tyler finds out, how's he going to feel about it?
I was 18, I was stupid, I wouldn't think about my actions beyond a minute into the future. I was a dumb kid not thinking about it. Deroon claimed that what he learned about Tyler during the legal proceedings, including information not made public, convinced him his actions did not cause Tyler's death. It would be kind of obnoxious of me to think I could have this profound effect on him, Darroon said. After all this time and reading his conversations and how and what he was doing before, I really don't think he cared at all.
I feel like I was an insignificant part of his life. In reference to a suicide note Tyler had left in his book bag, the contents of which have never been made public, Derun said. The fact that we weren't allowed to read it, that they said it didn't have anything to do with this, that gave me comfort also because I figured if it has nothing to do with me, it must have been something else that was going on. He had bigger problems in his life.
Derun said he felt frustrated not knowing if the final messages he sent to Tyler were ever read. Still, he likes to tell himself they were, saying, saying, to this day, I just say, you know what? I'll just think he read it, and he got it, and I'm going to accept that as that's what happened. At least he had to hear what I had to say. In response to these remarks, Tyler's older brother, James Clemente, offered this rebuke. In his 2020 interview, Darun states, I feel like I was an insignificant part to Tyler's life. That's giving me comfort now. What reasonable feeling person could look at the facts of this case and come to such a conclusion? The total lack of compassion and shifting of blame for his own actions seeps through
every word Deroon speaks about his crimes. How can he think that he was an insignificant part of my brother's life when he knows that his Twitter profile was the last thing Tyler saw on his computer before deciding to end his life. For so long I have craved to hear some small amount of recognition, awareness and humanity from Deroon. I have had to accept that this likely will never happen. I have found a vindication in knowing that an unbiased jury with no preconceived notion of this case or the players involved was able to see past the lies and understand the heart
of what happened. I hold these small comforts close and with gratitude, but there is nothing that can ease the pain of my loss. I love my brother, and I will mourn for him every day for the rest of my life. Darun Ravi was released from jail 10 days early. In 2016, following a 2015 New Jersey Supreme Court ruling that declared part of the law under which he was charged unconstitutionally vague, he petitioned to have his convictions overturned. An appellate court agreed, finding the law had been improperly applied. Consequently, Daroon pleaded guilty to a lesser third-degree felony charge of attempted invasion of privacy. He was sentenced to time served and fines paid, with all remaining
charges dropped. In the wake of her youngest son's death, Jane Clementi entered what she called a depressive fog that led to profound reflection. Tyler was sad, she said. He felt lonely. He felt he couldn't be himself, and that grieves me greatly. We were in two very different places, and I didn't know maybe how to support him at the time. He was a whole part of me. It leaves you with a whole, within. Christmas, Tyler's favorite holiday, which is in the same month as his birthday, is now unbearable for Jane. Although still religious, Jane and her family have since left the evangelical church they once belonged to, having come to reject its critical stance on
homosexuality. I think some people believe sexual orientation can be changed or prayed over, Jane said. But I know sexual orientation is not up for negotiation. I don't think my children need to be changed. I think that what needed changing is attitudes, or myself, or maybe some other people I know. Turning her grief into purpose, Jane is now a prominent advocate for the LGBTQ plus community and their rights. She is also the co-founder and CEO of her.
the Tyler Clemente Foundation, which aims to end all forms of bullying in schools, workplaces and faith communities. I couldn't have another son harmed by the world. I had to figure it out, she said. No one should ever feel as unworthy as Tyler felt. We want youth who are struggling in an unsupportive environment to know there is a whole loving community out there that loves them just the way they are. If it helps just one person, it's worth it. Joe and Jane Clementi offer heartfelt advice to parents of other LGBTQ plus children. Joe said, The way you react is important so that there is a positive outcome. When your child comes out, they need to know they are accepted, not broken or in need of fixing. Coming out is a risk and
parents should embrace their children fully, no matter their sexual orientation. That's how children know they're loved and made the right choice by being open. Jane adds, Sexual orientation is not a choice. Your child didn't choose this, and it can't be changed. Clinging to false beliefs causes great emotional and psychological harm, which research shows can lead to serious physical and emotional wounds. Tyler's older brother James also works with the foundation. Calling suicide completely preventable, he highlighted how many Rutgers students failed to intervene during Tyler's ordeal. The foundation focuses on empowering bystanders to
become upstanders who actively report and prevent bullying. Having since come out as gay himself, James offers this message to LGBTQ-plus youth. Hang in there, stay strong, there is nothing wrong with you. You deserve to love yourself and accept yourself fully. Tyler Clementi's tragic death has become a powerful symbol of the struggles faced by LGBTQ plus youth, particularly in the digital age. In September of 2010, Tyler was one of four LGBTQ-plus teens who died by suicide in the US after being harassed online. The prevalence of such experiences helped his story resonate nationwide, igniting a collective call-to-action.
Public figures like Ellen DeGeneres and President Barack Obama raised awareness, while artists such as Rise Against and Madonna honoured Tyler through their work. His death helped accelerate New Jersey's adoption of one of the toughest anti-bullying laws in the country, mandating staff training, bullying reporting and safety protocols in schools. The law's passage galvanized advocates and inspired further education reforms, including teaching LGBTQ plus history in schools. However, anti-bullying advocates say their fight has become harder under the US's current federal administration, which has backed sweeping legal changes that weaken protections for LGBT-plus individuals.
Rutgers University itself has also transformed since 2010, enhancing student support services, embracing diversity, and establishing the Tyler Clemente Centre for Diversity Education and Biase Prevention. The university now emphasises intersectionality ensuring LGBTQ plus students are affirmed in all aspects of their identities. To this day, Darun Ravi maintains that he acted without malice and denies ever targeting Tyler because of his sexual orientation. But the Clementies feel very differently. James Clementi believes Tyler never stood a chance as Derun
Deroon's roommate. In his view, Deroon dismissed Tyler not just as a potential friend or peer, but as a person, the moment he discovered Tyler might be gay. From that point on, James argued, Tyler was no longer seen as someone worthy of kindness or respect, but as someone to mock, violate, and use as a prop for impressing others. While Deroon might never fully grasp the fear and pain he inflicted, James said he would never stop thinking about it. The rejection, isolation and disdain his brother must have felt from his peers haunt him. Despite Deroon's insistence that the harm he caused was minimal, James points out that it's not the perpetrator who defines the damage, it's the victim. Of course it was reasonable for Tyler
to think that he was targeted for his sexual orientation. James said. What other reason would Darun Ravi have had to treat him so cruelly? What offence had Tyler ever done to him? For James Clementi, what stands out most is not just what Daroon did, but what he failed to do in the aftermath. In all the years since Tyler's death, James has never seen any genuine remorse, compassion,
or acknowledgement of the pain his brother endured. Neither Deroon Ravi nor Mully Wei have ever offered a direct apology to the Clementi family. James has wondered whether Deroon is even capable of empathy. Nothing in his behaviour during the time he lived with my brother, or since his death, suggests this to be true. In their opening statement during Deroon Ravi's 2012 trial, the prosecution shared the following quote from Réh. renowned psychologist Frank Baron. Never take away another person's dignity. It means everything to them and nothing to you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.